You are listening to radio
lab radio from W N Y.
S. T. E.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
And you know what this is, is radio that,
yeah. Okay.
So we're going to play you a little
bit of tape first just to set up the,
what we're going to do today.
About a month ago we were doing the
thing about the fake news. Yeah.
We're very worried about a lot of
fake news. A lot of people are.
But in the middle of
doing that reporting, we,
we were talking with a fellow from
Vanity Fair. My name is Nick Dalton.
I'm a special correspondent
for Vanity Fair.
And in the course of our conversation,
nick and this had nothing to do what
we were talking about, by the way,
nick just got into a sort of a,
well he went into a kind of a nervous
reverie, I'd say. Yeah. He was like,
you know, you guys want to talk about
fake news, but that's not actually,
it's eating at me.
The thing that I've been pretty obsessed
with lately is actually not fake news,
but it's automation and
artificial intelligence. And uhm,
and driverless cars because it's going
to have a larger effect on society than
any technology that I think has ever
been created in the history of mankind.
I know that's kind of a
bold statement, but, uh,
but you've got to imagine that you know,
that there will be in the next 10 years,
20 to 50 million jobs that will just
vanish, uh, to automation. Um, you've got,
you know, million truckers that
will lose their jobs. Um, uh,
the, but it's not,
we think about like automation
and driverless cars and
we think about the fact
that, um, they are going to, uh,
the people that just drive the cars,
like the taxi drivers and the
truckers are going to lose their jobs.
But what we don't realize is that
there, there are entire industries that,
that are built around
just cars. So for example,
if you're not driving the car,
why do you need insurance?
There's no parking tickets because you're
driving this car knows where it can
and cannot park and goes and finds
a spot and moves and so on. Um,
if there are truckers that are no longer
using rest stops because driverless
cars don't have to stop
and pee or take a nap,
then all of those little rest stops
all across America are effected.
People aren't stopping to use the
restrooms, they're not buying burgers,
they're not staying in these
hotels and so on and so forth. And,
and then you look at driverless
cars to a next level.
The whole concept of what a car is,
is going to change. So for example,
right now a car has five seats in
a wheel, but if I'm not driving,
well what's the point of
having five seats in a wheel?
You could imagine that
you take different cars.
And maybe when I was on my way here to
this interview, I wanted to work out,
so I called a driverless gym card or I
have a meeting out in Santa Monica after
this and it's an hour.
So I call a movie car to watch a movie
on the way out there or office car and I
pick up someone else and we have a
meeting on the way and all of these things
are going to happen, not in a vacuum,
but simultaneously. This, you know,
pizza delivery drivers are going to
replace by robots that will actually cook
your pizza on the way to your house in a
little box and then deliver it. And so,
kind of a little bit of a along with an
answer, but I truly do think that, um,
that it's gonna have a
massive effect on society.
Am I stressing you guys out? Are you,
are you having heart palpitations over
there? My blood pressure has gone.
Doesn't that? So that's a fairly
compelling description of, uh, of a, um,
of a very dangerous future. Yes.
But you know what? It's funny, uh,
one of the things that, I mean, we,
we couldn't use that tape
initially at least, right?
But we kept thinking about it because
it actually weirdly points us back to a
story we did about a decade ago.
The story of a moral problem that's
about to get totally re-imagined.
It may be that what nick is worried
about and what we were worried about 10
years ago have now come
dangerously close together.
So what we thought we'd do is we are,
we're going to play you this story as
we did it then sort of the full segment
and then we're going to
amend it on the back end.
And by way of just disclaiming,
this was at a moment in our development
where there's just like way too many
sound effects. Just gratuitous.
You don't have to apologize.
I'm going to apologize cause it
was just too much, just too much.
And also like we talk
about the FMSI machine,
like it's this like amazing thing when
was, it's sort of commonplace now.
Anyhow, it doesn't matter. We're
going to play it for you. Uh,
and then talk about it
on the back end. This,
we start with a description of
something called the trolley problem.
You Ready? Yup. Alright.
You're near some train tracks.
Go there and your mind. Okay. There
are five workers on the tracks working.
You've got their backs turned to the
trolley, which is coming in the distance.
I mean they were repairing the track,
they were repairing the descent.
Unbeknownst to them, the trolley
is approaching. They don't see it.
You can't shout to them. Okay. And if
you do nothing, here's what will happen.
I think workers will die. God,
I was a horrible experience.
I don't want that to happen. But
you didn't. But you have a choice.
You can do a nothing or B.
It's so happens next to you is a lever
pull the lever trolley will jump onto
some sidetracks where there is
only one person working. So if the
send the trolley goes on the second
track, it will kill the one guy. Yeah.
So there's your choice.
Do you kill one man by pulling a lever
or do you kill five men by doing nothing?
Well, I'm going to pull the lever
naturally. Alright, here's part two.
You stand in near some train tracks.
Five guys are in the tracks just as
before and there is the trolley company.
Same five guys working and five guys
back to the train. They can't see. Yeah,
exactly. However, and I
made a couple changes.
Now you're standing on a foot
bridge. The past is over the tracks.
You're looking down onto the tracks.
There's no lever anywhere to be seen
except next to you. There is a guy.
What do you mean as a guy, a large guy,
large individuals standing next to you
on the bridge looking down with you over
the tracks and you realize, wait,
I can save those five workers if I push
this man, give him a little tap. No,
no hills land on the tracks.
Hey, stop the train. Oh man,
got to do that. I'm not going to do that.
But surely you realize
the math is the same.
You mean I'll say four
people this way? Yeah. Yeah,
but this time I'm pushing
the guy. Are you insane?
All right. Here's the thing. If
you ask people these questions,
and we did starting with the first,
is it okay to kill one man
to save five using a lever?
Nine out of 10 people will say yes,
yes, yes. Yeah. But if you ask them,
is it okay to kill one man to
say five by pushing the guy,
nine out of 10 people
will say no, no, no, no.
It is practically universal.
And the thing is if you ask
people why is it okay to murder?
Cause that's what it is.
Murder a man with a lever and not
okay to do it with your hands.
People don't really know. Pulling
the library to save the five, no,
that feels better than pushing
the one to save the five.
But I don't really know why. So that's
a good, there's a good moral quandary,
Maria. Huh?
And if having a moral sense is a unique
and special human quality than maybe we,
we us to humans anyway,
you and me should at least
inquire as to why this happens.
And I happen to have met somebody
who has a hunch.
He's a young guy at Princeton
University, wild, uh, curly here,
but the mischief in his eye,
his name is Josh Goon. Alrighty.
And he spent the last few years trying
to figure out where this inconsistency
comes from. How do people
make this judgment,
forget whether or not these
judgements are right or wrong,
just what's going on in the brain that
makes people distinguish so naturally and
intuitively between these two cases,
which from an actuarial point of
view are very, very, very similar,
if not identical.
Josh is by the way a philosopher
and in neuroscientists.
So this gives him special powers. He
doesn't sort of sit back in a chair,
smoke a pipe and think, now why do you
have these differences? He's just, no,
I would like to look inside people's
heads because in our heads we may find
clues as to where these feelings of
revulsion or acceptance come from
in our brains. Hi.
So we're here in the control room where
you basically just see and it just so
happens that in the basement of
Princeton, different things, one,
there was this, um, yeah, yeah.
Wow. Big circular thing. Yeah.
It looks kind of like an
airplane and [inaudible]
180,000 pound brains.
I'll tell you a funny story.
You can't have any metal in
there because the magnet,
so we have this long list of questions
that we ask people to make sure they can
go in. Do you have a pacemaker or have
you ever worked with metal, blah, blah,
blah blah. Have you ever with metal? Yeah.
Cause you could have little flecks of
metal in your eyes that you would never
even know are there from
having done metal working.
And one of the questions is whether or
not you wear wig or anything like that
because they often have
metal wires in with that.
And there was this very nice woman
who does brain research here,
who's Italian and she's asking
her subjects over the phone, all,
all these screening questions. And
so I have this person over to dinner.
She said, yeah, you know, I
ended up, uh, doing this study,
but it's asked you the weirdest
questions. This woman's like,
do you have a head of, and, and I'm like,
what does it have to do with
if I have herpes or not?
And I want to say it anyway. And she
said, you know, she asked you, she said,
do you have a hairpiece? But she, uh,
so now she asks people if
you wear a wig or whatever.
Anyhow, what Josh does is he
invites people into this room,
has them lie down on what is essentially
a cot on rollers and he rules them into
the machine. Their heads are braced.
So they're sort of stuck in there.
They were done this, oh yeah, Yup.
Several times and many tells them stories.
He tells him the same too, you know,
trolley tales that you told before.
And then at the very instant that they're
deciding whether I should push the
lever or whether I should push the man.
That instant the scanner snaps
pictures of their brains.
And what he found in those pictures
was a frankly a little startling. Uh,
he showed us some, I, I'll, I'll,
I'll show you some, some, some stuff.
Okay. Let me think. The picture that
I'm looking at is this sort of, uh,
it's, it's a brain looked,
I guess from the top down,
top down and sort of sliced, you know,
like, like a, like a Deli slicer.
And the first slide that he showed
me was a human brain being asked the
question, would you pull the lever?
And the answer, in most cases was yes,
but pull the level when
the brain saying yes,
you'd see little pint of
peanut shaped spots of yellow.
This little guy right here and
these two guys right there,
the green was being active in these
places and oddly enough when ever people
said yes, yes, yes to the lever
question, the very same pattern lit up.
Then he showed me another slide. This
was a side of brain saying, no, no,
I would not push the man. I will not
push the large man. And in this picture,
this one we're looking at here, this,
it was a totally different constellation
of regions that lit up. This is the,
no, no, no crowd. I think this is
part of the no, no, no crowd.
So when people answer yes to the
level of question, there are,
there are places in their brain
which glow, but when they answer, no,
I will not push the man,
then you get a completely different
part of the brain lighting up.
Even though the questions
are basically the same,
what does that mean and what
does Josh make this? Oh,
he has a theory about
this. A theory, not proven,
but I think that this is what
I think the evidence suggests.
Suggest that the human brain doesn't
hum along like one big unified system.
Instead he says, maybe in your brain,
in every brain you'll find little
warring tribes, little subgroups,
one that is sort of doing a logical
sort of counting kind of thing.
You've got one part of the brain that
says, Huh, five lives versus one life.
Wouldn't it be better
to say five versus one?
And that's the part that would glow
when you answer yes, I'd pull the lever.
Yeah, pull the lever, but there's
this other part of the brain.
Would you really,
really like personally killing another
human being and gets very upset that the
fat man ks and shouts in effect? Oh No,
you don't understand it on that
level and says, no, no, no, Dad,
don't do never do everything.
A couple of books now
instead of having sort of one system that
just sort of churns out the answer and
bing, we have multiple systems,
they give different answers and they
Duke it out and hopefully out of that
competition comes morality.
This is not a trivial discovery that
you struggle to find right and wrong
depending upon what part of your brain
is shouting the loudest. This is,
it's like bleachers, morality.
Do you buy this? Hmm.
Ah, you know, I, I just don't know.
I always kind of suspected that a sense
of right and wrong is mostly stuff that
you get from your mom and your dad and
from experience that it's culturally
learned. For the most part, Josh is
kind of a radical in this respect.
He thinks it's biological.
I mean deeply biological that somehow
we inherit from the deep past,
a sense of right and wrong.
That's already in our brains from
the get go before mom and dad
are our primate ancestors,
before we were full blown,
humans had intensely social lives.
They have social mechanisms that prevent
them from doing all the nasty things
that they might otherwise be interested
in doing. And so deepen our brain.
We have what you might call basic primate
morality and basic primate morality
doesn't understand
things like tax evasion,
but it does understand things like
pushing your buddy off of a cliff. Ah,
so you're thinking then that the man on
the bridge that I'm on the bridge next
to the large man and then I have hundreds
of thousands of years of training in
my brain that says don't
murder the large man. Right?
Whereas even if I'm thinking
if I murdered the large man,
I'm going to save five lives
and only kill the woman,
but there's something
deeper down that says,
don't murder the large
man right now, that case,
I think it's a pretty easy case even
though it's five versus one. In that case,
people just go with what we might call
the inner chimp, but there are other,
but their unfortunate way
of describing an act of,
of deep goodness. That's interesting.
10 Commandments forgot
inner chimp, right? Well,
what's interesting is that we think of
of basic human morality as being handed
down from on high,
and it's probably better to say
that it was handed up from below,
that our most basic core moral values
are not the things that we humans have
invented, but the things that we've
actually inherited from other people,
the stuff that we humans have invented
or the things that seem more peripheral
and variable,
but something as basic
as thou shalt not kill,
which many people think was handed
down in tablet form from a mountaintop,
from God directly to humans.
No chimps involved, right?
You're suggesting that
hundreds of thousands of years
of on the ground training
have gotten our brains to
think, don't kill your kin,
don't kill your these, you know, that
should be your default response. I mean,
certainly chimpanzees are extremely
violent and they do kill each other,
but they don't do it. As a matter
of, of course, they, so to speak,
have to have some context sensitive
reason for doing so. So, hey,
how are we getting to the rubber that
you think that profound moral positions
may be somehow embedded in
brain chemistry? Um, yeah,
and Josh thinks, uh,
there are times when these different
moral positions that we have embedded
inside of us in our brains when
they can come into conflict.
And in the original episode
we went into one more story.
This one you might call
the crying baby dilemma.
The situation, uh, is,
is somewhat similar to the last episode
of Mash for people who are familiar with
that. But the way we told
the story, it goes like this.
It's wartime [inaudible]
patrol coming down the road.
You are hiding in the basement
with some of your fellow villagers.
Let's kill those lights. And
the enemy soldiers are outside.
They have orders to kill
anyone that they find
quiet. Please nobody make a
sound until the pastors. So
you are,
you're huddled in the basement all around
your enemy troops and you're holding
your baby in your arms,
your baby with a coat, a bit
of a sniffle. And you know,
the good baby could cough
at any moment. [inaudible]
they hear your baby. They're going to
find you and the baby and everyone else,
and they're going to kill everybody.
And the only way you can stop this from
happening is covered the baby's mouth.
But if you do that, the baby's
going to smother and die.
If you don't cover the baby's mouth,
soldiers are going to find everybody
and everybody's going to be killed,
including you, including your
baby, and you have the choice.
Would you smother your own baby to save
the village or would you like your baby
cough? Knowing the consequences,
and this is a very tough question.
People take a long time to think about
it and some people say yes and some
people say no
and children are a blessing
and a gift from God.
And we do not do that to children. Yes,
I think I would heal my baby to
save everyone else and myself. No,
I would not kill the baby.
I feel because it's my baby.
I have the right to terminate the life.
I'd like to say that
I would kill the baby,
but I don't know if I'd
have the inner strength.
Know if it comes down to killing my own
child, my own daughter or my own son.
Then I choose that.
Yeah, if you have to do,
because it was done in World War Two
when the Germans were coming around,
there was a mother that had a baby that
was crying and rather than be found,
she actually suffocated the
baby, but the other people live.
Sounds like an old mash. They know
you do not kill your baby. Okay.
In the final mash episode,
the Korean woman who is a
character in this piece,
she later, sure baby. She
killed it. She killed it.
Okay.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
I didn't mean for it to kill it.
I just wanted that to be quiet.
It was a baby.
Great kids mothered around bay rate
[inaudible].
What Josh did is he asked
people the question,
would you murder your own child
while they were in the brain scanner
and adjust the moment when they were
trying to decide what they would do.
He took pictures of their brains
and what he saw,
the contest we described
before was global in the brain.
It was like a world war.
That gang of accountants,
that part of the brain was
busy [inaudible] calculating,
cut a whole village could die
of old village, could die.
But the older and deeper reflects also
was lit up shouting, don't kill the baby.
No, don't kill the baby. Go inside.
The brain was literally divided.
Do the calculations. Don't kill
two different tribes in the brain.
Literally trying to just
shout each other out. And Jen,
this was a different kind of contest
than the ones we talked about before.
Remember before when people were
pushing a man off of a bridge,
overwhelmingly their brains
yelled, no, no, don't push the man.
And when people were pulling the
lever overwhelmingly, yeah, yeah,
pull the lever right there.
It was distinct here.
I don't think really anybody wins.
Well who breaks the time and they had
to answer something, right? Yeah. Yeah.
That's a good question.
And now is there a,
do you, what happens, is it just two
cries that fight each other out or
is there a judge?
Well that's an interesting question
and that's one of the things that we're
looking at
when you are in this moment with
parts of your brain contesting,
there are two brain regions, these
two areas here towards the front,
right behind your eyebrows,
left and right that light up
[inaudible]
and this is particular to us.
He showed me a slide that's
those uh,
sort of areas that are very highly
developed in humans as compared to other
species.
So when we have a problem that we
need to deliberate over the light,
the front of the brain, this is
above my eyebrow sort of. Yeah. Yeah,
right about there. And
there's two of them.
One on the left and one
on the right, bilateral.
And they are the things that monkeys
don't have as much of that. We have,
certainly these parts of the brain are
more highly developed in humans. Oh,
looking at these two flashes of
like at the front of a human brain,
you could say, we are looking
at what makes us special.
No.
So that's a fair statement. They
human being wrestling with a problem.
That's what that is. Yeah.
Where it's both emotional,
but there's also a sort of irrational
attempt to sort of sort through those
emotions. Those are the cases that are
showing more activity in that area.
So in those cases, when these dots
above our eyebrows become active,
what are they doing?
Well, he doesn't know for sure, but what
he found is in these close contests,
whenever those nodes
are very, very active,
it appears that the calculating section
of the brain gets a bit of a boost.
And the visceral inner chimp section
of the brain is kind of muffled.
Oh Hey
[inaudible]
people who chose to kill their children,
who made what is essentially a logical
decision over and over those subjects had
brighter glows in these two areas
and longer glows in these two areas.
So there is a definite association between
these two dots above the eyebrow and
the power of the logical brain over
the inner chamber or the visceral
right. Well, you know,
that's the hypothesis.
So it's going to take a lot of more
research to sort of tease apart what these
different parts of the brain are doing.
Or if some of these are just sort of
activated in incidental kind of way.
I mean we really don't know.
This is all, all very new
[inaudible].
Okay. So that was the story we put
together many, many, many years ago,
about a decade ago.
And at that point the whole idea of
thinking of morality is kind of purely a
brain thing.
It's relatively new and certainly the
idea of philosophers working with MRI
machines, that was super new.
But now here we are 10 years later
and some updates, uh, first of all,
Josh Green. So in the, in the long,
long [inaudible] the theme of times,
I assume now you have a three
giraffes, two Bob's rats and children.
Yeah. So two kids and we're, we're close
to adding a cat. We talk to them again.
He has started a family. He's switched
labs from Princeton to Harvard.
But that whole time, that interim decade,
he has still been thinking and
working on the trolley problem.
Did you ever write the story
differently? Absolutely.
So for years he's been trying out
different permutations of the scenario on
people. Like okay,
by firing freshman in college,
instead of pushing the guy off
the bridge with your hands,
what if you did it but
not with your hands.
So in one version we asked people about
hitting a switch that opens a trap door
on the foot bridge and drops the
person in one version of that.
The switches right next to the person
in another version of the switch is far
away and in yet another version,
you're right next to the person and you
don't push them off with your hands,
but you push them with a pole.
Oh, and to cut to the chase, uh,
what Josh has found is it
the basic results that we
talked about that's roughly
held up still the case that people would
like to save the most number of lives,
but not if it means pushing somebody
with their own hands or with a Paul that
matter. Now here's something
kind of interesting. Uh,
he and others have found that there are
two groups that are more willing to push
the guy off the bridge.
They are Buddhist monks and psychopaths.
I mean some people just don't care
very much about hurting other people.
They don't have that kind
of an emotional response.
That would be the cycle bass,
where's the Buddhist monks presumably
are really good at shushing their inner
champs. He called it and just
saying to themselves, you know,
I'm aware that this is that killing
somebody is a terrible thing to do and I
feel that,
but I recognize that this has done
for a noble reason and therefore it's,
it's okay,
so there's all kinds of interesting things
you can say about the trolley problem
as a thought experiment,
but at the end of the day it's just
that it's a thought experiment.
What got us interested in revisiting
it is that it seems like the thought
experiment is about to get real.
That's coming up right after the break.
This is Amanda Darby calling
from Rockville, Maryland.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
I'm forming you as attorney Prepara.
My new podcast is called
stay tuned with pre,
it's about how power works in American.
I talked to justice department
officials to federal judges,
even to a former defense secretary.
And I tell the story of what
happened when Donald Trump fired me.
It's a collaboration between Wny c
studios, cafe and Pineapple Street media.
Get it wherever you get your pocket.
Yes,
Chad, Robert Radiolab. Okay,
so where we left it is it the
trolley problems about to get real.
Here's how Josh Green put it.
You know now as we're entering the
age of self driving cars, oh this is,
this is like the trolley
problem. Now finally come to life
owner's card. Oh,
the future of the automobile
is here on us cars,
autonomous vehicles. It's
here. Build this part first.
Self-Driving Volvo will be offered
to customers in 2021 ah oh.
Where's it going with this legislation
or the first of its kind focused on the
car of the future. That is more
of a supercomputer on wheels.
Okay, so self driving cars, unless
you've been living under a muffler,
they are coming. It's going to be a little
bit of an adjustment for some of us.
We hit the brakes. But what Josh meant
when he said it's the trolley problem
come to life is basically this.
Imagine this scenario.
Self-Driving card now is, uh,
headed towards a bunch of
pedestrians in the road.
The only way to save them
as to swerve out of the way,
but that will run the car into a concrete
wall and it will kill the passenger in
the car.
Ah,
what should the car do? Should
the car go straight and run over,
say those five people or should
it swerve and, and, and, and,
and kill the one person
that suddenly is a real world question.
[inaudible]
if you ask people in the abstract like
what theoretically should a car in this
situation do, they're
much more likely to say,
I think you should sacrifice
one for the good of the many.
They should just try to do the
most good or avoid the most harm.
So if it's between one
driver and five pedestrians,
logically it would be the
driver driver. Be Selfless.
I think it should kill the driver.
But when you ask people,
forget the theory,
would you want to drive
in a car that would
potentially sacrifice you to save the
lives of more people in order to minimize
the total amount of harm?
No, I wouldn't buy it. No. Absolutely not.
That would kill me in
it. No. So I'm not going,
I'm not going to buy a car that's
going to purposely kill me. Hell No.
I wouldn't buy it for sure. No,
I'll sell it, but I wouldn't buy it.
So there's your problem.
People would sell a car and an idea of
moral reasoning that they themselves
wouldn't buy. And last fall
and exec at Mercedes-Benz
face planted
right into the middle
of this contradiction.
Welcome to Paris, one of the most
beautiful cities in the world.
And Welcome to the 2016 Paris motor show
home to some of the most beautiful cars
in the world.
Okay. October, 2016, uh,
the Paris motor show,
you had something like a million people
coming in over the course of a few days.
All the major car makers
here is Ferrari. You can see
the LaFerrari Abeta and of course
the new gt four seat Luso t
everybody was debuting
their new cars. Endo.
One of the big presenters in
this whole affair was this guy.
In the future you'll have cars where you
don't even have to have your hands on
the steering wheel anymore, but,
but maybe you watch a movie on the head
up display or maybe you want to do your
emails. That's really
what we're striving for.
This is Christoph on Hugo, a senior
safety manager at Mercedes Benz.
He was at the show sort of demonstrating
a prototype of a car that could sort of
self-drive its way through traffic
and this e-class today, for example,
he's got a maximum of
comfort and support systems.
You'll actually look forward to being
stuck in traffic jams when you, of course,
of course,
he's doing dozens and dozens of interviews
through the show and in one of those
interviews, unfortunately this one
we don't have on tape. He was asked,
what would your driverless car do in a
trolley problem type dilemma or maybe you
have to choose between one or
many and he answered quote,
know you can save
one person at least say that one.
If you know you can save one
person, save that one person.
I use the one in the car.
This is Michael Taylor corresponder
for car and driver magazine.
He was the one that Christoph
on. Hugo said that too.
If you know for sure that one thing one
day is can be prevented and that's your
first priority.
Now, when he said this to you [inaudible],
did it seem controversial
at all in the moment?
In the moment it seems incredibly logical.
I mean all he's really doing is saying
what's on people's minds, which is that,
no, I wouldn't buy it.
Who's going to buy a car?
The chooses somebody else over
them. Anyhow, he makes that comment.
Michael Prince it and
a kerfuffle ensues. Say
the one in the car. That's
Christoph von Hugo from Mercedes. But
then when you look at the questions,
you sound like a bit of a heel because
you want to save yourself as opposed to
the pedestrian. Doesn't it ring though
of like just privilege? It does. Yeah,
it does. What would you do? It's you or
a pedestrian and it's just, you know,
I don't know anything about
this pedestrian. It's just
you were a pedestrian,
just a regular guy
walking down the street,
screw everyone who's not in a Mercedes.
And there was this kind
of uproar about that, uh,
how dare you drive these selfish, you
know, make these selfish cars. Uh,
and then he walked it back and he
said, no, no. What I mean is that, uh,
just that we, that we have a better chance
of protecting the people in the car,
so we're going to protect them because
they're easier to protect. But of course,
yeah, there's always going
to be trade offs. Yeah.
And those tradeoffs could
get really, really tricky
and subtle because obviously
these cars have sensors,
sensors, like cameras, radars, lasers,
and ultrasound sensors.
This is Raj Rajkumar.
He's a professor at Carnegie Mellon.
I'm the, uh, code director of the GM,
CMU connected and autonomous
driving collaborative research lab.
He is one of the guys that is writing
the code that will go inside gms a
driverless car. And he says, yeah,
the sensors at the moment on these
cars still evolving. Pretty basic.
We are very happy if today can
actually detect a pedestrian,
can detect a bicyclist or motorcyclist,
different vehicles of different shapes,
sizes and colors.
But he says it won't be long before you
can actually know a lot more about who
these people are.
Eventually they will be able to detect
people of different sizes, shapes,
and colors. Like, oh, that's a
skinny person. That's a small person,
tall person, black person, white
person. That's a little boy.
That's a little girl. So
forget the basic moral math.
Like what does a car do
if it has to decide, oh,
do I save this boy or this girl?
What about two girls versus one boy
and an adult, but a cat versus a dog,
a 75 year old guy in a suit versus that
person over there who might be homeless.
You can see where this is going and
it's conceivable the cars will know our
medical records. And back at the car
show we've also had that term car to car.
Uh, also one of the enabling
technologies in highly automated driving.
Mercedes guy basically said in a couple
of years the cars will be network,
there'll be talking to each other.
So just imagine a scenario where like
cars are about to get into accidents and
right at the decision point
they're like conferring.
Well who do you have in your car? Me,
I've got a 70 year old Wall Street guy
makes eight figures. How about you? Well,
I'm a bus full of kids. Kids have
more years left. You need to move.
We'll hold up.
I see that your kids come from a
poor neighborhood and have asthma.
So I don't know.
So you can basically tie yourself up and
knots a wrap yourself around an axle.
We do not think that any programmer
should be given this major a burden of
deciding who survives and who gets killed.
I think these are a very
fundamental, deep, uh,
issues that society
has to decide at large.
I don't think a programmer eating pizza
and sipping coke should be making the
call.
How does society decide? I
mean, help me imagine that.
I think it clearly has to
be an evolutionary process.
I believe Raj told us two things
basically need to happen. First.
We need to get these
Robo cars on the road,
get more experienced with how they
interact with us human drivers and how we
interact with them and to their need
to be like industry wide summit.
No one company is going to solve that.
This is Bill Ford Jr of
the Ford Company, uh,
giving a speech in October of
2016 at the Economic Club of DC.
And we have to have,
because he could you imagine if we had
one algorithm and Toyota had another and
general motors had another,
I mean it would be amiable
obviously couldn't do that.
What if the Tibetan cards
make one decision in the
American cars make another.
So we need to have a national
discussion on ethics I think of,
because we've never had to
think of these things before,
but the cars will have the
time and the ability to do that
live a colleague,
boys this pasta so far,
Germany is the only country that we
know of that has tackled this head on.
One of the most significant points the
ethics commission made is that autonomous
and connected driving is
an ethical imperative.
The government has released a code of
ethics that says among other things that
self driving cars are forbidden to
discriminate between humans and almost any
way not on race, not
on gender, not on age,
nothing shouldn't be
programmed into the cars.
One can imagine a few
classes being added, uh,
in the Geneva Convention, if you will,
of what these automated vehicles should
do. A globally accepted standard,
if you will.
How we get there to that globally accepted
standard is anyone's guess and what
it will look like.
Whether it'll be like a coherent set
of rules or like rife with the kind of
contradictions we see in our own
brain. That also remains to be seen,
but one thing is clear.
Oh, there are cars coming.
Build this with their
questions. Let me back from
me controlling it. Oh
dear Jesus. I could never,
oh, where's it going? Oh my God.
Okay.
We do need to caveat all this by saying
that the moral dilemma we're talking
about in the case of these driverless
cars is going to be super rare.
Mostly what will probably happen is
that like the plane loads full of people
that die every day from car accidents.
Well that's just going to hit the floor
and so you have to balance the few cases
where a car might make a decision you
don't like against the massive number of
lives saved.
I think I actually have a a
different thing I was thinking,
even though you dramatically
bring down the, the,
the number of bad things
that happen on road,
you dramatically bring
down the collisions.
You dramatically bring down the mortality.
You dramatically lower the number of
people who are drunk coming home from a
party and just ram someone sideways and
killing three of them and injuring two
of them for the rest of their lives.
Those kinds of things go way down,
but they're the ones that remain,
are engineered like
they are calculated, uh,
almost with foresight.
[inaudible] so here's the difference and
this is just an interesting difference.
Like Ah Damn,
that's so sad that happened that that
guy got drunk and kind of that maybe he
should go to jail.
But you mean that this
society engineered this in.
That is a big difference.
One is operatic and seems like the
forces of destiny and the other seems
mechanical and pre fought through.
He meditated and there's something dark
about a premeditated expected death and
I don't know what you do about that.
Everybody's on the hook for that.
The killers
in the particular as it feels dark,
it's a little bit like when you know,
should you kill your own
baby? Did you save the villas?
Like in the particular instance
of that one child, it's dark,
but against the backdrop of the
life saved. It's just a tiny bit
pinprick of darkness. That's all.
Yeah, but you know how humans are.
If you argue back that yes,
a bunch of smarty pants is
concocted a mathematical formula,
which meant that some people
had to die in here they are.
There are many fewer than
before a human being.
Just like Josh would tell you,
we'd have a roar of feeling
and of anger and saying,
how dare you engineer this
in? No, no, no, no, no.
And that human being needs to meditate
like the monks to silence that feeling
because the feeling in that case,
it's just getting in the way.
Yes and no, and that may be impossible
unless you're a monk for God's sake.
See, we're right back where we started
down. Yeah. All right. We should go.
Chad, you have to thank some people. No,
yes.
A this piece was produced by Amanda
Arran check with help from Bethel Hob Tay
special thanks to e odd Rawan,
Edmond Awad and Sidney Levine from
the moral machine group at MIT.
Also thanks to Suretec Karaman Chin Chang
and robo race for all their help,
and I guess we should go now. Yeah,
I'll, um, I'm Jad Abumrad
not coming into your car.
You don't mind? Just take my own,
I'm going to rig up an autonomous
vehicle to the bottom of your bed,
so you're going to go to bed and suddenly
find yourself on the highway driving
you wherever I want
anyhow. Okay. We should go. Yeah,
I'm [inaudible] I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.